this i think was from about a week ago
again i'm getting caught up on all this
stuff
when uh he defended himself after
calling magger republicans semi-fascist
what do you mean by semi
[Music]
fascism lindsey graham said last night
there would be riots in the street if
former president trump is prosecuted for
taking classified government documents
to mar-a-lago what is the white house
response to that so
um
we have you know we have seen mega
republicans attack our democracy we have
seen mega of republicans take away our
rights uh make threats of violence uh
including this weekend and that is
what the president was referring to
when you all asked me
last week about the semi-fascism comment
so if i can link this back to a little
bit of where we started with sam harris
stuff the point here is is that sort of
like sam harris they're now saying the
quiet part out loud they are okay
uh silencing people whether it's through
big tech or whatever means they see fit
they are okay using the fbi to
investigate the former president or
whether they want to hire i'm told 87
000 new irs agents to look into your
finances so that the government can take
more of your money armed agents by the
way they're saying all the quiet things
out loud they call you fascist they call
donald trump fascist the idea that he
would use the power of the state and and
corporations to crack down on people
while they're the ones who are doing it
they were the ones who used the levers
of the state to influence corporations
during covid to fire the very people who
earlier were deemed the essential
workers firing nurses who wanted to my
body my choice every everything they say
is a lie you and you when you know it it
frees you it absolutely frees you uh so
we just showed i hadn't seen her in
about a month that was uh black lesbian
press secretary corinne
jean-pierre and then she said something
even more insane uh this is just from
yesterday i mean this one is really
really wild and and well i'm not going
to tee up any further than to say does
this sound like
true freedom to you or mob rule again we
see majority of americans who disagree
and so when you are not with where
majority of americans are
then you know
that is extreme that is an extreme way
of thinking
i mean if she believes that she there's
so much history that this woman needs to
learn but that that is what these people
think if most people believe something
is right and true then it must be right
and true and if you do not
you
are the radical you are the extremist i
mean that is mob rule on steroids that
is how all of the awful movements of
history that is how pogroms and
holocausts and all sorts of horrible
things happen a majority starts getting
drunk on power starts following a bad
leader and then is willing to do all
sorts of bad things to the minority the
uh you know you could have a group of 20
people
and just because 19 people
say that 2 plus 2 equals 5 it doesn't
mean that the one guy who says 2 plus 2
is 4 is the extremist i mean this is
just absolutely extraordinary but again
it fits doesn't this all sort of fit
like a puzzle into everything that's
been going on here for quite some time
so so what does this all kind of lead us
to because now we are in the fall it is
september and that means we are
basically two months away from these
midterm elections and yes it does at
least at the moment look like there's
going to be this massive red wave and
that's partly why biden
is using the scary imagery and this
magger republican
it's partly why he's doing that because
all they've got is they need people to
be fearful whether it's fearful of the
the maga extremists or whether it's
fearful of covet or monkey pox or
something else all they have left
is that you will need us because you
will be
afraid okay we're also about nine months
away from the republican primary season
now so a bunch of republicans are going
to get in
on the the presidential stage and we'll
see how that thing fights out and i hope
that it's a robust
fight but again all of this leads to
that we have the we have a really
bizarre two months in front of us right
now because the biden administration
clearly is out of control irs agents
everywhere going to investigate trump at
mar-a-lago uh all half the country are
terrorists and an election on the
horizon